في لقاء خاص لقناه العربيه مع رائدى
الفضاء السعوديين على الجرني وراينا
برناوي الزميل حسن الطالعي يتحدث معهم حول
التجارب والتدريبات المهمه وهذه المهمه
التاريخيه
ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى يتم
تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد اتمنى
مؤخرا الجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات مجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
هذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا
من القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وكذلك
بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود الى ارض
الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف المرجوه من هذه
الرحله
نتابع ايضا مشاهدينا مع رائده الفضاء ريان
برناوي التي تصف مشاعرها بعد اختيارها ضمن
المهمه العلميه الى الفضاء
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه الباط الباط حق المختبر
حقي وخلاص طالعه من البيت رايحه على دوامي
اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء سعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه ولا انا الان رائده فضاء او باحثه
ما صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحكم
عملي في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا
اسكن في الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص
اللي مهمين بالنسبه لي هي
ام الوالده كنت حابه اني اقول لها الخبر
وهي في جده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت كذا من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذه الخبر
العظيم
سوف نقوم باجراء سته تجارب في الطب البشري
وهذا التجارب تعنى بدراسه التغيرات على
التي قد تصيب الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام
وكذلك النظر هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها
في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه
سوف يتم استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في
الفضاء بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه التجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات